it's a semi-open file and now it's white
to play here so think about it for a
little bit and try to evaluate this
position and see who is better and why
white is isolated pond but it's very
well protected and also makes the e7
pond weak
so if you have to give me an evaluation
who do you think is better here and
whether or not white is slightly better
maybe much better or maybe it's just
equal
it's why to play like to play
space space yes okay you want to take
this night well yes I mean white is one
thing white is more active and a 7-point
is weak but one thing you don't want to
take on a six here because if you take
he takes lots of weak dark squares now
an e7 pawn is not that weak anymore okay
so you don't want to take one f6 in this
position but so you think white is
better white is slightly better or white
is a big advantage if you think white is
better here if you had to evaluate this
position here yes
very good white is much better here
actually you make a good move here and
after that it's a big advantage and one
more thing I'm looking for you to
mention here why white is better if you
look at the position carefully you will
notice that there is a reason white is
better so that's excellent
why white almost completely developed
except his Queen which is going to
develop next month and look at the rooks
see black is yet to develop these pieces
so you actually have a leading
development issue your pieces are more
active and you have pressure from the
first class it doesn't really look like
black is really in big trouble here but
fuels the fuel's later you will see is
gonna have a big problem session so
what's the best move here for white
white we know now that white is much
better here but what's the best position
yes
94 you could do that but before 94 is
probably good but before you do 94 you
want to complete the development in
general it's a good idea to finish the
development before you think about
attacking ok so what's the right move
here to finish the development and stop
him from moving your bishop see he wants
to push this yes absolutely Queen d2 not
only you develop your Queen you stop the
h6 move and also you just connected your
rocks ok so it's all around an excellent
move it's always good to make a move
that will combine several ideas and here
you combine stopping this move
connecting the rocks and developing a
piece so Queen d2
and now he played Queen d7 developing
the Queen and trying to connect the
rooks and now a very strong move you
need to find here because if you don't
play energetically for the next few
moves and you allow block to get this
rook in and get this piece in you will
have maybe a slightly better position
but not a big advantage so you always
have to try to recognize in which
positions you need to play energetically
and which positions you need to slowly
build up like in a previous game you see
I was just building up but their
position like this it's a more of an
open position and more concrete play
needed here now white is a strong move
here and our target is the e7 weak pawn
you could go up into a tree but he just
goes rook fe8 and and in general you
don't want to attack with the Queen
because it's easier to defend because
even if you pile up you can take with a
queen so you want to wait on the Queenie
tree head you have a better move here
yes excellent Knight e4 activating the
night putting pressure on f6 and also
threatening to go where with this night
absolutely
95 also threatening Kish so black
doesn't have that much choice so he
takes now how are you gonna take back
with a partner with the rook absolutely
not even a question
you're not gonna take with a pawn and no
more pressure on the e7 I mean slight
pressure and you can put this bishop in
now I'll have an excellent square for
the bishop and normally you don't want
to block your rook if you're rookies on
a half-open fire semi-open file you
don't want to block it so now you take
rookie for putting pressure here so he
has to go here now rook c2 you wan
putting pressure and now in this
position black has two options first of
all who can tell me why f6 is losing why
is this move losing d6 discovery check
with a bishop and then you can just take
on the same f6 is very bad if you place
he plays Bishop f8 that's the move but
if you place Bishop f6 what do you do
for for white
you take it he takes it next move is
very important because if you don't play
this move you're not gonna have a big
advantage absolutely d6 you want to push
this pawn not only it's gonna be strong
because also it will open the position
of your Bishop and now after you have a
pawn on d6 what is your threat the rook
to e7 so that's why it's gonna be very
strong for you to have a pawn on d6 so
Bishop f6 is bad because of that oh by
the way I actually wanted to show you a
line if it takes tags sorry now I go
smoke da what's the best move here for
white don't rush
think when it's very important not to
rush if you go rookie 7 he takes on d6
and you take he takes back with the rook
and the problem is Jason background ok
the background is a problem so you
always have to be extremely careful if
there are threats
you could go Queen d5 but you have
something even better than that
yes something better than Queen d5
see he's threatening to take the pawn on
d6 not yet not yet we're not we're not
ready not ready for sacrifices
I mean Bishop f7 and Queen takes f7
what's the follow-up Queen takes Queen
who is the movie suggested but he just
he takes on d6
quick-quick
- III see actually that you have a
tactical idea that you need to see here
you have a tactical idea here 24 he
takes on these six now I think now you
will find them move them because you see
the idea you see the idea rook e8 you
have that what you want to do to prevent
his idea first quiet h3 after which now
can he take the pawn check if he moves
away we take the rock and we wrap a rope
and if he takes our rook we take the
Queen and we don't have to worry about
the background right because we have the
escape square for the King so it's very
important to find a movie hd because if
you don't find h3 here you're not gonna
have a big advantage you're gonna have
to put your rope back here and defend
and you might not win because then he
will bring his bishop to a better
position put the King on g7 you you have
advantage but you're not breaking
through here okay but after h3 you win
because you go rookie 7 next okay like
okay we can look a little bit more if
you like
you go here check can't come here if you
he probably has to go back here and then
what's the winning move me
from age seven which he said he can't
even go to d1 because we should takes so
that's why he played in this position he
played Bishop f8 and now what do you do
not yes you have lots of pressure but
looks like he is defending it what can
you do to break through now so he cannot
defend anymore this is 7 pound very nice
idea for white here d6 and if I capture
Pathak's text
critics I did it's interesting to open
it up but you have to calculate make
sure you have something because you lose
the palm you're not gonna have that much
compensation you don't wanna change you
don't wanna change your bishop with this
bishop yes it sure is an idea but you
have something stronger let stuff move
to find because you have to look at it
this way which piece is defending the
position of the black king and also
protecting his main weakness bishop his
bishop is a very important piece here so
you go Bishop h6 and now he's in big
trouble because you want to take his
bishop if he takes back with the rook he
loses the pot so after Bishop h6 black
played Queen d6 Bishop takes now he took
with the rook and after this white is
idea up upon an excellent excellent
position winning but if it takes to the
Queen what do you do do you see the idea
now Queen check the rock h4 that's it
see that Bishop is a very important
piece here okay that defending his king
and also defending the weakness by
exchanging this bishop now you take
advantage of the weak dark squares that
he has see I think this is a very
important moment here to actually find a
mortgage paycheck it's not a move you're
gonna find because we are thinking a
little bit differently usually during
the game we take it all we have an
active piece and he has a passive case
and normally we don't think about
exchanging it but here you need to
realize the bishop on a faith as a very
important role it's actually defending
is the only
the king has here is the bishop so you
eliminate the defender you activate the
Queen and then you swing the rook over
and you win the game okay so basically
in the game block after Bishop 860
played Queen d6 and takes takes rook e7
he played okay see it and after queen d4
black just one black is gonna win
another point on a7 now and just winning
I mean in a position like this you have
extra pawn in a better position more
active pieces so one more thing I want
to ask you here what if he makes this
kind of wolf it's very important not to
get confused you know when opponent
makes a move that looks really kind of
strange move you just put the bishop
there because if you take it he wants to
take your Bishop on h6 if we take his
bishop he wants to make an in-between
move take your rock first you could do
rock edge fourth but you have something
better you could do rock edge form but
you have something better here
this takes h6 yeah let's think let's
think think about things they should pay
for right away here's b5 Bishop before
right away yes which pay for advice
here's b5 what can you do first
take the lights good bishop and he takes
very nice winning the exchange okay okay
excellent very good so we so and this is
how you can also improve your end game
you know you get into position
absolutely improve your middle game
because this is we were just right after
the opening this is the middle game here
where you look at the position and you
try to come up with a plan in the middle
game the most important thing is to find
the right plan adhere your promise to go
Queen D to develop the Queen and then go
Knight e4 and put pressure in a key move
of course what's the most important move
in this position Bishop h6 where exactly
you have a better bit more active piece
but you exchange the space because his
bishop is defending the king and the e7
calm
okay so this is how you play when you
have the open file or semi open file
more like a semi open file because the
the main plays on the e-file so it's how
to play on the semi open file okay okay
now what I would like to do is I would
like to do a couple of in-game studies
with you okay so this is gonna be very
difficult but it's really creative ideas
that you need to find how many of you do
endgame studies when you were training
to do you know any famous study
composers studies are positions that are
not actually played they're composed
there they actually haven't even have
grandmasters in compositions this
studies yes kasparian exactly Kasparian
yes ready
not sure might be ready but another one
it's very famous composers throw its key
throw its key there
gooble true it's key kasparian these are
very famous composers okay so now we
will do some exercises on studies okay
I'd like to do studies and that was part
of the training that I had when I went
to the world champion Tigran Petrosian
chess school in Armenia a lot of my
homework was studies very difficult but
I had to do it spend hours and try to
solve one position sometimes you really
stuck and then then you realize there is
some idea you start analyzing this is at
that time we didn't have computers or
anything now any position you see you
can solve in two seconds
you set up interests place you put the
engine it will give you the answer but
when I was training we didn't have
computers or anything so white to play
and win normally in a position like this
if blocking is safe and the queen is
next to it it you can't really win a
position like this unless you have some
concrete way to win but this is a very
specific position here
y can actually win this okay not an easy
position
so first let's calculate a little bit
what white can do here to win obviously
you have to win the queen or made them
that's the only way we can win in this
position there's not that much material
left on the board
the first one is very natural first move
is very natural so let's put the first
move in Queen c7 check right what he
goes here now let's think now let's
think of how we can try to follow it up
the problem here is if you just make a
move with your night black queen is
going to start checking you and you
don't have any pads or any pieces that
you can hide behind so here we'll just
start checking you all over the board
and then it's gonna be a draw because
you're gonna have to interchange your
queen it's gonna be a draw so you're
really not gonna have a place to hide
your king so that's one you have to be
very careful when you allow him to check
you okay excellent now he has to play
King b7 why do you see the win here
Queen b6 if it goes here very good if it
was king c8 excellent so he has to go
here nice you let's think let's think a
little bit you try to calculate well 98
the problem is you run into this move
okay
the move Jason is saying it's correct
but I want you to calculate a little bit
okay what's gonna happen after this
check
yeah but the night is kind of awkward
here because it's it's kind of pinned
now I think yeah you you got Queen d5
maybe but it's they're not pleased the
right way you know like they're not it's
not the right mechanism you know you're
not gonna be able to so the 95 is the
correct move now black is losing if he
goes here you see how skewer Queen 84 if
it was here he is losing also because of
school a so it was here a lot of times
when I set up this study for my students
they get to this they think they're
gonna go check check and mate because
typically when you reach the position
like this you go Queen b6 Queen b7 and
its mate but here this little bit
different this 7 score is guarded so
it's not like you can just go check
check and wait mate here
Queen b6 check I can't go to the corner
right because you make me so I have to
go here not this one so it's important
to know that not always in order to win
these positions you have to go check
check check
a lot of times your last move is a quiet
move like in this particular there are
many studies I can set up for you that
final move is a quiet move sometimes you
just need to pass the turn okay
do your opponent and but but here you
have to do it carefully because I told
you you cannot allow him to trick you
because if it was queen g4 strip g6
check you you're not gonna win this game
he's gonna start checking so you go King
D - quiet move now King cannot move
right so the only piece can move is the
Queen now let's see where the Queen came
over and again keep in mind he needs to
keep control of this court so he doesn't
have done many options
what is the only move he can make to
keep control of the square without
losing and then we go back to your idea
because now his own piece is obstructing
his Queen his his Queen is obstructing
the King here and he can't do anything
but I mean again I mean it's almost
impossible to find this if you don't
practice studies you know you really
have to practice and be familiar with
this idea of quiet move not all this is
gonna be check check check and win those
are kind of easy but you got make couple
of important checks and then think about
the quiet move okay let's do this one
more time and I hope you will remember
this position and the idea for many many
years okay so let's start again we start
with okay who wants to say the first
move go ahead
King Day a remember if he goes to b8 we
go Queen b6 and then mate on c7 with a
knight or claim so he has to go here
continue not my DA 95 check he has to go
to be 8 otherwise he loses the Queen to
a skewer 6 check can go to the corner
queen bee 7 mate has to go here check
and the final move the most difficult
move to find here is the move King D to
step back so the Queen cannot check you
and you pass the turn and he doesn't
have any options here if it moves away
he gets mated the only way to keep
control of that school is to go here but
then you check and the queen is now
controlling that square that king could
have gone in the earlier line ok with
the queen bee a alright
ok let's do one more and anybody wants
to write down this position so they have
this this is the original position
ok so if you want to write it down this
is it
king d3 Quincy 496 blocking is on b8
quinone 8 white to play a winner
ok ok
so net position we have is this position
white to play yeah white to play what do
you think what should be looking for
here yeah so I mean white should be
aiming for a way to avoid getting made
it
Queen h3 is coming right so the problems
even though you have two rooks is
usually it's not weaker than the Queen
but in this particular position the
rooks are placed kind of awkward and now
he's threatening to make you on h3
square so he's starting just to go here
and mate I'm only one move that will
help you to save this game any other
move you make you're gonna lose
let's don't rush let's think about it
you have to kind of think of an idea how
can you try to draw this game
kingi to rock g2 is losing do you see
how see when you leave a rook unguarded
it's very risky in an open board you
leave a piece unguarded couple of tricks
and then suddenly you can drop the rock
okay so you make sure you don't do that
check check okay that's the problem here
we you don't have the freedom of moving
our pieces because we are in danger of
losing one of the rocks and then we lose
the game okay let's let's don't rush
let's let's not try to guess if rook
doesn't work we move the King let's
that's not a very good way to find the
solution
yes
look h1
I check
up
see rooks are awkward now they're not
connected his King is in yeah yeah
actually yeah right yeah yeah I'm sorry
I just I was thinking about the
different line but I was gonna use this
and it works here too okay
I was actually I'm sorry I was looking
at in this line if you go here you go
check this is what I was thinking and
then you win this way okay because no
more checks and then you get made it and
if you go here black actually goes first
here forcing you to check and then only
he goes here to mate because if he goes
here immediately what do you do check
and then you connect and it's draw it's
all about consolidating the position for
white if he can do that he can hold this
but he really can't do that yes okay so
what's the move
there's a problem with it check an f1
you can't go to here right me so you can
never bring his came across check see
the problem is I'm not gonna let you
step up to connect the rooks and now you
go either side you gonna lose one of
your rocks done that's the problem
yeah that's the thing problem is our
rooks are not coordinated well they're
not place well here only one move can
draw this game any other move I mean you
almost mentioned all the moves now which
rook zero do you one correct
obviously not see you one right because
I mentioned to you that there is a mate
here yeah so look so you want okay but
it looks like wait a minute check
that's the main move Queen tricks you
got the right book right here you have
to find the right move here King to h1
correct because if you go to g1 you lose
after this move and you get made it
again you go to each one actually and
now he comes up and now looks like it's
just gonna be over yeah he's gonna meet
you here you can't check here you can
check here he takes both rocks what do
you do now we're rooks III check
sacrificing the rook he's got to take it
because if he goes back you solidified
and you cut the King off okay now he
cannot make you with the Queen he needs
to use his king to do that so now he's
got to take it okay three check okay
then look like it's gonna be that hard
because not that many pieces on the
board but you really have to calculate
this position that you're gonna be able
to reach okay so let's do this one more
time again if you want to write this
down this is the position King H to the
rook g1 rook c1 King on h4 for black
Queen on d3
white to play and draw okay again we'll
start out with which move here rook ge1
check King it fun yeah in this studies
you have to be very precise you can't
really do two different moves it's
usually only one solution have to be
very precise King each one looks like
now mate is gonna be coming Queen G 2
Queen fh2
now Roxy three checks sacrificing the
rook
he's got to take it now we go rocky 3
and now he takes and it's gonna be a
still made okay everyone thanks for
coming and we will have some more
lectures this week so I hope you can
come